Listing education is your next step
in building your master resume.
An important thing to note about
the education section, is that it can
include a variety of forms beyond
the traditional college experience.
Just be sure to present this in an
organized way on your targeted resume.
Within the education section,
include any degrees,
certificates, credential, etc.
Also note, high school education
need not be included on your resume
after college.
When organizing this information,
organize the category,
university degrees,
certificates, courses, workshops.
This helps visually
organize your experience.
Within each subheading, place the most
recent experience at the top.
It might be helpful to note that you
don't need to include the specific years
that you graduated.
You didn't have to include a GPA, but
if you've got a great GPA, a 3.5 or
above, for example, you can.